Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Mon métier est exigeant, mais je l'aime.
Dans quelle entreprise a-t-on l’occasion
de s’émerveiller quotidiennement
devant la vie,
d’assister à la venue
au monde d’un petit être ?
En général, la maman fait ça toute seule.
On surveille juste.
Imaginez ce petit être tout frêle,
encore tout tremblant,
qui ouvre ses grands yeux sur le monde.
Moi, ça m'émeut toujours autant.
Et cette mère sait, personne
n’a besoin de lui montrer.
Elle le protège, le rassure.
Un vrai moment d'amour maternel.
Poussé par son élan vital, ce petit être
essaie aussitôt de se mettre debout.
En quelques heures, il est déjà sur ses
pattes et cherche les tétines de sa maman.
Il est bien plus dégourdi
qu’un petit humain
à qui il faut plus d’un an
pour apprendre à marcher.
Je regarde aussitôt son sexe.
J’espère qu’il s’agit d’une femelle,
car après l’élever trois ans,
elle deviendra maman à son tour
pour vous fournir du bon lait.
Vous l’aurez compris, j’élève des vaches,
près d’Orcival,
dans les montagnes d’Auvergne.
Et si vous avez dans l’idée que
l’activité d’élevage est solitaire
et nourrit difficilement son homme,
je voudrais vous dire
qu’il peut en être autrement.
Mais pour cela, il faut penser son modèle
et ne pas avoir peur de remettre
en question les vieilles habitudes.
Des modèles agricoles,
il y en a plusieurs.
Voilà comment j'ai imaginé le nôtre.
La première condition,
c’est d’être rattaché à son territoire
et de chercher à en tirer le meilleur.
En produisant du Saint-nectaire fermier,
on bénéficie d’une AOP,
gage d’expression d’un terroir,
d’une qualité reconnue
et d’une authenticité contrôlée.
Nous travaillons en bio,
ce qui donne un peu plus
de valeur à notre production
et contribue à respecter
l’environnement et nos animaux.
Nous sommes des écologistes des champs,
des agro-écologistes,
et cherchons à mettre
les nouvelles technologies
au service des savoir-faire traditionnels.
La deuxième condition,
c’est d’optimiser nos activités.
Et chez nous, c’est varié.
On a installé un méthaniseur, un séchage
en grange et des panneaux photovoltaïques.
Le méthaniseur nous permet, avec les
déjections des vaches et le petit lait,
de fabriquer du biogaz qui sera transformé
en électricité et en chaleur.
Son sous-produit,
le digestat, sert à fertiliser nos prés.
Ce qui nous dispense d’acheter
des engrais souvent chimiques,
pas très écologiques.
Le séchage en grange nous permet
de sécher l’herbe en bâtiment
pour préserver toutes ses valeurs
et nourrir au mieux les animaux l’hiver.
Ils bénéficient d’une partie
de la chaleur de la méthanisation.
Nous avons posé des panneaux
solaires sur les toits.
Ce qui produit une grosse partie
de l’électricité que nous consommons.
On a ouvert un restaurant
sur notre commune, à Orcival,
pour aller du sol à la fourchette.
J’aime quelquefois y partager
mon expérience de producteur.
Je parle souvent du Saint-nectaire
et j’insiste toujours sur l’intérêt
d’en manger la croûte
pour nourrir notre microbiote.
Un véritable probiotique.
Accompagner la vie microbienne
de notre sol jusqu’au fromage,
c’est le cœur de notre métier.
Nous sommes donc des éleveurs de bonnes
bactéries, sources de santé et de saveurs.
La troisième condition, c'est l'équipe.
Une équipe suffisamment nombreuse,
formée de gens
complémentaires et passionnés.
Si beaucoup d’éleveurs travaillent
seuls, nous, nous sommes quinze,
six associés et nous sommes
sept de la même famille.
Nous sommes même seize si je compte
Rick, mon chien de berger, mon ami,
toujours à mes côtés, surtout au moment
d’aller chercher les vaches.
Mon frère Olivier gère les troupeaux.
Il faut un hectare par an
pour nourrir une vache :
la moitié pour la faire pâturer l’été,
l’autre moitié pour faire le foin
qu’elle va manger l’hiver.
La vache, elle mange devant
et bouse derrière.
Elle fertilise donc le sol en avançant.
Il faut donc la changer
de pâture régulièrement
pour que tout soit mangé
et fertilisé de manière raisonnée.
Ni sur pâturer, ni sous pâturer
pour bien respecter à la fois
la vache, la plante et le sol.
Si beaucoup de collègues
labourent leur sol
pour semer des herbes plus productives,
nous préférons
une herbe de prairie naturelle.
Et ce sont les vers de terre
qui s’occupent du travail du sol.
Nous élevons donc des vers de terre,
sources de vie des sols.
Dans un sol en bonne santé,
Il y a un équivalent de trois vaches
en vers de terre,
c’est-à-dire 1,5 à 2 tonnes par hectare.
Lydie et Jean-François aiment les moutons.
Mais avoir des moutons,
ce n’est pas qu’un choix affectif.
Ils valorisent les prés les plus pentus
qui seraient dangereux pour les vaches.
Ce sont également de bons défricheurs.
Mais attention, ils aiment bien
les jeunes arbres.
Et cette année,
on a planté 600 mètres de haies.
Ce qui constitue un bon abri naturel
et fera plus tard une protection pour les
vaches contre le soleil et contre le vent.
Nous travaillons sur le temps long.
Pour faire un Saint-nectaire,
il faut quinze litres de lait,
soit à peu près huit litres par kilo.
Un Saint-nectaire pèse 1,7 kg.
Le fromage, ça sert donc
aussi à conserver le lait
et à le transporter facilement.
Céline, ma sœur,
c’est la responsable de la fromagerie
et de la cave.
Nous affinons nos fromages
pendant plus d'un mois.
Un bon fromage, c’est comme un bon vin :
à chaque étape,
de sa fabrication à son affinage,
on peut tout faire échouer.
C’est un processus chronométré, délicat,
et il faut gérer le temps
à une cadence soutenue.
La fromagerie,
c’est notre atelier de production,
mais c’est aussi notre salle de sport.
Yvonne, ma femme, elle, c’est la gestion,
et elle s’occupe
de la partie administrative.
Nous sommes dans une activité
très encadrée et très contrôlée.
C'est normal, on nourrit la population.
Yvonne est précieuse
parce que beaucoup d’entre nous
font des phobies administratives
et peuvent même se décourager.
Moi, je me sens le capitaine de l’équipe.
Je coordonne,
je prévois les besoins en personnel,
le renouvellement des matériaux,
je m’occupe des projets.
Et au quotidien,
eh bien, je trais les vaches.
On trait à quatre et je participe
aux traites matin et soir.
Sitôt fini, je vais à mes petits veaux.
Nous élevons toutes nos femelles
et elles boivent du lait jusqu’à
environ leur quatrième mois.
Je les connais par leur nom.
Je veille du mieux que je peux
à leur santé.
Si besoin, j’appelle le vétérinaire,
disponible 24/24.
J'ai toujours un œil sur la météo.
C'est elle qui rythme notre travail.
En famille, avec Yvonne et les enfants,
on fait le marché de producteurs de Jaude.
On organise de nombreuses
visites de la ferme.
J'aime expliquer notre volonté
d'économie circulaire.
Sol, herbe, plantes, vaches,
retour au sol.
Je suis fils et petit-fils d’agriculteurs.
Mais j’ai travaillé pendant 20 ans
en nutrition animale
comme technico-commercial.
Et il y a seulement sept ans
que j’ai décidé de m’installer
* avec l’opportunité, la reprise
de la ferme [inaudible] d’Orcival,
qui, ajoutée à la ferme familiale,
a permis ce projet.
Nous sommes en fin
de phase initiale de notre projet.
Nous démontrons
que notre ferme est viable et durable.
Mais ça n'a pas été facile.
Il a fallu convaincre les banques,
le projet leur paraissait risqué.
Il fallait créer une équipe,
que l'équipe s'entende.
Il fallait investir massivement.
Notre environnement était perturbé
par de la jalousie locale,
notre modèle agro-écologique pas toujours
partagé par tout le monde,
mais je crois que le jeu
en valait la chandelle.
Maintenant, nous sommes lancés.
Notre enracinement local est fort,
et notre vie d’équipe fonctionne.
Lorsque j’étais salarié,
je n’avais qu’un seul chef.
Maintenant, j’en ai beaucoup.
Les clients.
Je dirais, comme François Michelin, que
le patron des patrons, c’est le client.
Les administrations.
Elles ont un pouvoir considérable
sur notre métier.
Nous sommes soumis
à une très forte réglementation.
Elle s'alourdit d'année en année.
La pression est assez lourde.
Et enfin, la nature.
Comme le dit l’adage,
on ne commande à la nature
qu’en lui obéissant.
Ses lois sont impératives.
Elles ne sont ni bonnes ni mauvaises,
elles sont.
À nous de les découvrir,
de les respecter et de les partager.
Je me lève tous les jours
à 5 h pour vivre ma passion.
C’est beaucoup de contraintes, pour moi,
mais surtout pour ma famille.
Mais je crois que c’est dans ces
contraintes que j’ai trouvé ma liberté.
Je me sens heureux et chanceux
de faire de ma passion mon métier.
J'en éprouve un sentiment
d'accomplissement personnel.
Et mon ambition aujourd’hui, c’est de
vous montrer qu’il est possible de rêver
et de réaliser son rêve.
Ce qui est le cas pour
moi dans notre ferme.
Je vous remercie de votre écoute.
(Applaudissements)